on the shoulder but you know it's a soft
play everybody's okay it's just a
regular file
but this is where it gets good where
luca is saying um
that's not good you guys can read his
lips but porzingis comes over and and if
you are
the clippers you you want to impose your
will you finish smith
comes up short and
harold hits the ground and it's going to
be on doncic
oh now dodgers just looked down and look
who coming off the bench make sure
donches just looked down at montrez
herald while he was on the ground
and as a player that's something you
can't do to me
or i'm gonna jump up and ask you what
you're looking at
what you're looking down at so when we
see this situation again that's where
that kind of stems from but
we set it in the open and this is a
heavyweight fight and both teams
are ready to go double tech here harold
and doncic each getting a t
i'd like to see this double tech though
i know it's the playoffs i don't want
so no that's not a double tech that's a
tech on luca doncic
that's not a double tech lucas is the
only one that threw his left arm and he
threw montrezl to the ground now
he says stop flopping big man that's
when i got to get up and show you what a
flop is but again you love the heart of
luca but that should not have been
a double foul every time one guy falls
and they get in each other's face
it's not double